how about you okay here we go
okay here we go
this weekend
meet your Rebels
two Rebels
one hell of a show
[Applause]
it's the rebels with a cause Comedy Tour
this Saturday December 3rd in Baltimore
Maryland for the last show of the Year
tickets on sale Atlanta with credit.com
tour
[Music]
don't you have a good Christmas
yeah pretty good
get everything you wanted
almost
done well
that's life I guess there's always next
Christmas
yep
say that's funny
what's that over there
where behind the desk over there go take
a look
[Music]
oh wow Mom and Dad and Walter BBQ nine
millimeter with a four inch barrel and A
5.6 pound trigger ball wow
thanks Mom and Dad
[Music]
Brown face
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
delicious hey uh tool man bring up CNN
really quickly really quickly do it do
it do it do it there you go just because
he was giving me crap before the show he
was mad that I didn't have my headphones
on what are you doing where's your
finger on the trigger button
wow yeah he's like having a conversation
to like little three seconds before it
well I was talking about the show little
Tit for Tat and by the way we will be
talking about Alyssa Milano and the
Twitter meltdown as far as uh what that
means for you also uh Biden's a trans
department what's the the transgender
individual who was in charge of nuclear
waste we'll be talking about that turns
out as a criminal surprise
and we'll be talking about the
Balenciaga Scandal look this is pretty
important to discuss right now because
and again I try and wait sometimes our
rule here is either be first or be best
meaning be the most accurate that we can
be if we don't have all the information
now we have more information in the
Balenciaga Scandal the whole you know
what people have been referring to is
organize Satanism a cabal of satanists
um here's the thing
it's bad
and it's been bad in the entertainment
industry for a very long time to be
clear but there's a lot of
misinformation going around on both the
left and the right and what do I mean by
that is not are these people degenerates
of course they are right I mean this is
a rhetorical question but when people
put up a picture saying hey this is the
creative director and it's not or hey
this is another ad campaign and it never
existed we need to do better than that
that's just my opinion we'll be playing
age restricted or not because it's
appropriate on Mud Club never on YouTube
Gerald a how are you I'm doing well I'm
a little pissed off that we're going to
be talking about so much pedophilia
today because it exists yes
you have to shed the uh you have to shed
the whole the christianese skin because
we have to address the world that we
like I find addressing it I just hate
that it exists so do I but you know what
I will say this I'm really grateful that
you know we're not Pastors in a church
as people you know we're very open about
our faith but these are issues that they
can't talk about this is the problem
with the Christian church that can't
offer answers if they say there's
darkness in the world do you mean uh
children fondling bondage bears
oh I can't say that why because it'll
offend my congregation they should be
offended if they know the world that
they're living in so we get to address
and sometimes we go too far I get it
sometimes I look back and say oh I can't
believe we did that
my bad you know him you love him fastest
man on his feet we are finishing up the
torch your last chance Baltimore
December 3rd there's still some tickets
I I think it's mostly singles because a
lot of crowd.com shortlouder with
crowder.com tour Dave Vanda how are you
Ahoy good how about you good I think I
need new headphones again
it keeps going from one ear to the next
like like Revolution number nine really
I got a strange animal Christmas shirt
by the way it's comfy oh yeah
I like them the company that you use
here by the way the only reason I don't
wear the Ahoy shirts and they're also
available at the shops because they were
I've worn them but it's it's it was
during covid the the horrible
manufacturer where they sent out
remember like 200 that just not quite
gilded but almost as crappy as Gildan
for that they're better now yes they're
better now they're back to the soft nice
fabric so I have some questions for you
today we'll be asking them repeatedly
because I think it's an important
discussion first off what is satanism
can you answer that kind of hobby really
yeah Dabble
Sammy Davis Jr yeah that Jewish Satanist
missing an eye because of the uh
Cadillac hood ornament sorry uh honk the
the horn ornament yes the horn
um is it honked with his scalp yes
skull oh God
I better work
or maybe liver King which brings us to
another thing here and we're gonna have
some questions about steroids
look this shouldn't matter except it's a
microcosm of a bigger issue and you've
heard me talk about this a lot Instagram
ass models it's the same thing with
young girls right they go around this
this unrealistic standard of beauty that
people reject unless it's a man acting
as a woman then we embrace the Barbie
stereotype men have to live up to these
same kinds of standards only I would
argue
and you guys can disagree with me if you
want I'd love to hear your comments
below I would argue it's harder for the
man to actually uh sort of mimic what he
sees in magazines because we don't just
have to not be fat you have to be
incredibly muscular and lean and by the
way if you meet someone who has gained
muscle while losing fat congratulations
you've just met someone who's on
anabolic steroids or just taking pills
that are given to them in a baggie yes
like you're Notre Dame some than others
yes
um so the liver King has been uh is
going viral for a long time okay now he
has gone viral
for all the I mean I don't know right
reasons wrong reasons I don't care
eating livers and testicles I'm sorry
testicles yes raw and is the first clip
that we have is this is this it being
revealed that he's no this is him uh
eating tests okay this is how if you're
a parent you're saying who's a liver
King this is the person who all of your
children young men have been watching
and many were tricked into believing
that this man was all natural here's his
about one pound of delicious Raw Liver
right in front of me
and what they're doing you definitely
take Peds you know what [ __ ] I'm
going to be on for the all right here we
go I take Peds yeah I prioritize execute
and dominate everything every morning
every morning
believe achieve receive relieve really
what yeah so that's what he's famous for
now the woods and I eat I grew a big
silly beard yes I eat lamb fries I hold
the record yeah the funniest part is
when you see his wife uh where she has
to eat the real liver she's like I do it
too
[Laughter]
she dressed like a saint Paulie girl I
don't know why I feel like that would be
his wife that would be yeah exactly
that's exactly who it is every month is
Oktoberfest this is what we do so here's
the problem for those of course who
obviously know anything about human
physiology this is no surprise but this
is a bigger problem that we see now with
these social media influencers and
people can do whatever they want I just
ask that you do not lie to us this
brings us back to then
and back then you have the liver King
claiming for a long long time and this
is a debate he was all natural
it started with the accusation daddy or
not for the record for the record it's
Natty right never taking steroids I've
never had Peds other than prioritize
execute and dominate in life he's got an
ass full of steroids
I think what you're invariably some
people want to look like liver King they
want to look like me and what you're
saying is you got to do that if you want
to look like him and number one I don't
do it
well he has an [ __ ] or something
called it Natty yeah Natty I'm all Natty
bro what nutty ice your boobs but you
don't have veins in your nipples yeah
come on who doesn't this is all natural
in the way that it doesn't look natural
at all to anyone and a lot of people
believe this I've argued with people who
believe this uh well this brings us to
now and this shouldn't be a scandal but
an email was leaked and it does seem as
though this has been confirmed I can't
100 all references available at a lot of
creditor.com what his cycle is like
here's the thing he didn't just dabble
in steroids the steroid Lobby gave him
Dental in a company car
and just to be clear what we're about to
say is probably unpopular I don't think
that it's an all or nothing equation as
far as steroids as far as performance
enhancing drugs in in sports to be clear
all drugs are performance enhancing
drugs if you look at the the Olympic
Committee you can't take certain levels
of Advil certain two cups of coffee is
considered a ped if a doctor gives you a
medication and it is not a performance
enhancing drug you need to sue him for
malpractice so it's too broad of a term
but with the liver King okay his cycle
included uh well igf-1lr basically
you're talking about growth hormone he
was taking very high doses by the way of
a growth hormone or omnitrope I believe
is growth hormones tough to know some of
these are name brands CJC with a
ipmorelin uh he said that he'd been
taking it for a year Omni Trope he's
been taking that for six weeks he'd been
taking testosterone then you get into
high high level uh steroids meaning
these are steroids that only an
experienced user would use uh Deca for
example Deca cypionate he was taken out
he was taking Winstrol and by the way
Winstrol can turn your ligaments into a
fine powder these are not only these
aren't just performance dancing drugs
these are bodybuilding drugs yeah there
are performance enhancing drugs that
exist that can help you for example
Conor McGregor he just pulled himself
from the UFC this is important for
people to note he pulled himself he Frac
he snapped his tibia in half he notified
the commission and said hey it's about
being able to play with my kids in 10
years so he took something that wouldn't
be allowed on the usada banned list and
some of those things are actually
healthy some of those things will help
you recover but they are banned then he
took these uh he took these drugs and
now he's back in the testing pool I
don't think that it's all steroids
completely untested or no steroids at
all they were created for a purpose if
you actually watch like Dallas Buyers
Club yeah they were only taking a few
they were attacking steroids they can
give you steroids right now if you are a
burn victim if you have AIDS if you have
cancer right you're a wasting victim uh
if you're old with osteoporosis because
they work don't just be just be
blindsided by the fact that Barry Bonds
took nine times the prescription dose
Dallas Buyers Club I think I want to
look like that yes yeah
it would have been worse I'm kidding it
would have been like the movie sinner
yeah yeah well it kind of was yes in a
matter of speaking but the point is it
would have been thinner ER yes it would
have been thinner quicker well see
here's the thing this shouldn't come as
any surprise at the liver King right
yeah uh because it's easy to you know
fail the eyeball test when you compare
him to uh notorious all-natural athlete
The Rock Johnson also admits in the
interview that he's taken steroids
before I tried them when I was 18. me
and my football buddies nothing happened
Johnson said
foreign
yes because all men become more muscular
and lean as they get into their 50s yes
that's true yes 25 on the left yes
exactly and his forehead is four inches
taller yeah that happens looks like
Cro-Magnon man gosh the Mark Maguire
Berry bonds thing that was when I
finally liked baseball for half a second
it was really enjoying that was great
but I'm like
he's been like I don't know like a buck
95 his whole career and now he's like
240 with a bunch of like he's ripped
yeah he was a string bean then he came
out like a cartoon character yes from
one season yeah it wasn't a slow bill
that's like hey cover it up a little bit
you know they're hitting home runs so
far they're like should we make these
fields bigger
the coaches are like hey guys we're not
doctors we are giving away way too much
to the Make-A-Wish kids with all these
home runs boy this creatine stuff is
really nuts yes full natural diet here's
the thing look I don't know what your
opinion is on on steroids uh
I if you're doing them and you're doing
them and you're uploading pictures to
Instagram just don't lie about it right
I don't have as big of a problem with
people taking performance enhancing
drugs if they are honest about it I mean
everyone kind of knows right in the NFL
the testing it's like look here you go
here's a pharmacy let the games begin or
professional wrestling for a period of
time at least they don't have to try and
fame like they're drug testing the issue
is that you lie about it and then you
have young men who feel like they can't
live up to these expectations women
think you think you're the only ones who
have this problem imagine not just
having to lose weight but imagine having
to put on 20 pounds of muscle and be
leaner because that prick says I'm all
natural and you're just not working hard
enough and I understand there are some
people who aren't in shape and they
think that everyone who's bigger than
them is taking steroids it's not lost on
me I just don't think it's an all or
nothing equation but the problem is the
dishonesty that's when you have an issue
with young men yeah and so we focus on
young women all the time living up to
unrealistic Beauty yes you
going through some really unhealthy
eating habits stuff like that to be able
to look like somebody well for men it's
not just looking like this person it's
being strong like this person
competitive like this person able to do
the things this person does the real
problem with steroids comes when people
do it at a very young age that's when it
becomes very very dangerous for kids
because they don't know what they're
doing they're probably not getting the
best substances out there to put into
their body right and they're just trying
to get ripped for no other reason than
to be able to do these things right and
it can kill people very quickly at a
young age if you do it incorrectly you
can do it in an old age it doesn't it's
very rare that it kills people very
quickly at a young age but it can cause
serious problems there was a kid in a
school really close to where I went
there's a foundation set up for him now
that took steroids and took too much I
guess and it did lead to his death right
so was it liver failure I think so
something like that so you just took too
much of them and so they're trying to
let people know like hey hey kids don't
don't try to be like that so that's what
we're saying yeah you want to take
steroids as an adult when you can make
an informed decision and you want to
just look better and have better
performance that's I think the point
you're making like yeah fine just don't
know what I'm saying is I think for
example we have these athletes and we
ask them to go actual athletes not you
know bodybuilders yeah that's a sport no
it's not it's a modeling show whoever
most effectively Services weeder okay
let's be clear about what bodybuilding
actually is yeah athletes don't sit
there with their shirt off and
interviews yeah yeah no in a thong and
they go no I don't know his left delt
isn't symmetrical just call it the Mr
Gay competition
who's an almost naked guy oh it's just
one of the Cubs yes I'm sorry I mean
professional athletes yeah my bad
um no but I don't think it's an all or
nothing equation we ask these athletes
to go out and destroy their body of
course and of course you look at CTE and
of course you look at what happens in
the quality of life and the life
expectancy and we can give we can pump
them full of painkillers we can pump
them which they do all the time with no
problem well now now they haven't now
they've gone too far on they've gone too
far in that direction where people who
actually need them can't get any pain
medication like yours truly after having
his rib cage cracked open in three
titanium rods you're like you get six
stays I said you're bullshitting but two
at halftime no no you stumbled because
your back was hurting not because your
brain jostled around so hard in your
head right you don't know who you are
anymore but when yeah but you're 29 and
you don't know how to put on a shirt it
doesn't seem worth the money exactly
it's not so much put they don't know
where to find shirts I don't even know
where would I go to buy shirts is it the
same place where I buy my my goat
bladder no it's not you have a closet
you could just go to TJ Maxx I don't
know do they sell liver there you're
full of [ __ ] liver King wearing pants
around his arms is this right
he's wearing the front half of The
Little Rascals donkey outfit no that's
half a disguise I don't know
I just saw a closet I'm scared yes
steroids bad
right then people don't learn about them
there was a time in this country when
they could be prescribed to people they
were created for a reason they still can
prescribe them to you for example if you
burn yourself horribly but then if an
athlete snaps their ligaments we've seen
this happen time and time again they
can't recover because they can't even
take things that you can take that is
substances that aren't even illegal so
my problem just to be clear here is
really with people who take steroids and
lie about them in order to sell bull
crap to Young impressionable men we need
to do better with that and I think we
also need parents to have very Frank
discussions and you know what we've
talked about this here
I don't know should we let should we we
were going to do a steroid competition
here in this office for the first time
all of us because I don't think anyone
here has done it get on us one cycle
just so you can see how effective they
are it is mind-blowing you ever known
someone who's taking steroids but well
apparently I've known somebody very well
who took steroids and didn't know
anything about it yeah yes Gerald
vitamin baggies at Notre Dame I was very
very period of my life I have no idea
why why do you vitamins have powder yeah
why is it why do you have a full grade
professional grade food saver what is it
yeah this vitamin K just makes me punch
holes in everything yes
and why did I grow a revert why did I
lose my hair in Reverse Mohawk pattern
this is right weird I can rep out 500
squatting that's great but comment below
if you would like to see under the care
of a doctor a steroid competition in
this office just to see who becomes the
biggest freak Show all right I'll do it
by the way that was tool man he was like
we should do this we absolutely should
do this I'll tell you yeah I'll see what
I can do you'll be the you'll be the
control study where you do nothing and
take steroids and we see the results you
see what happens yeah oh I guarantee
you'll just you'll still get all kinds
of results just not the same are we
going to do an in-memorium for Dave yes
my heart just stops the second I use it
oh right well don't worry you'll be
listed as a coveted death so oh that's
true this is a live show Monday through
Thursday 10 a.m Eastern if you are
watching right now we're going to get in
some issues that I don't know if we'll
be allowed on YouTube the Balenciaga
Satanism so uh tune in hit the button
there you can always watch on Rumble
nothing would make me happier than
seeing these numbers right now on
YouTube
over to rumble and of course on mug Club
we'll be playing age restricted or not
where we take it to YouTube for the kind
of bull crap non-censorship that they
employ it's bad today because it's
YouTube against YouTube yes we Jiu Jitsu
YouTube yeah it's Jiu Jitsu tube oh oh
you should admonish me for that but
don't
it's better and that's because I was
talking all the way up to the show Okay
so let's get to this right Twitter
here's the deals of me making love
this is uh you know the world and we in
which we live right now of course um we
all know that uh Twitter now might allow
people who have opinions that weren't
allowed on Twitter like conservatives
like uh you know at one point the
sitting president so this of course has
to be met with a meltdown
the problem with the Meltdown is look I
just believe if you do something do it
100 if you are going to uh if you're
going to burn out if you're going to
have a mental breakdown then leave no
doubt
burn it all down the problem is when you
half-ass your mental breakdown and you
half-ass your walk out your boycott and
then you come back it's just incredibly
embarrassing it's like leaving a
restaurant like well I'm never eating
here again and you come back you you
forgot the horseradish yeah yeah you
come back for your coat son of a gun
it was specific because it happened yeah
did I leave a set of keys yes
[Music]
it's a Milano didn't about face right
she announced that she was going to be
leaving Twitter this is what she said
the other day she was going to be
leaving Twitter uh she was serious why
because Elon Musk is now in charge of
Twitter it's not enough that you have
Zuckerberg that yojickski that you have
Jeff Bezos that you have Tim Cook it's
not enough that there are five people
who control all the rest of the
information two companies control 95 of
everything on the app store or sorry
everything in the app market app store
that just tells you how ubiquitous it is
it's mostly the app store and then you
also have Android I get it all the
Android iPhone people you don't need to
start a rumble in the comment section
you're all welcome here so Alyssa Milano
decided that she was going to leave
Twitter then she went on The View and
she said yeah no actually I'm not going
to do that uh it's uh I've changed I
changed I changed my mind you know I
always open Twitter with like yeah you
know what I mean like put a helmet on
because I'm so scared like something's
gonna come out and hit me yeah yeah do
you think you'll stay on it yeah because
we can't see that territory it's like a
Turf War now
well I I don't disagree with the
sentiment that's why I don't think the
conservatives should just abandon
YouTube but you obviously shouldn't
self-censor to the point where YouTube
is no longer of any value yeah uh she's
just she just yells the kinds of insane
things that only you know the absolutely
crazy Lament
so well yeah she gets a reaction for
what she puts out it's not so much like
random attacks nobody's gonna go at you
because you're on who's the boss right
it's because you say dumb crap all the
time and Charmed sucked yeah she does
never watched it no neither did I I
should say it's not an educated opinion
I just feel like throwing shade yeah and
I'm gonna agree yeah I never say it
either but I bet you it's terrible
doesn't it make you feel big yeah I feel
big saying that yeah she's a woman I'm a
man yeah thrashing it take her down
that's the only reason I don't care I
don't care how good looking you are or
if you would have rebuffed my advances
in high school so I'm the WB how could
it be good
I guess she stayed on
because she wanted to continue tweeting
stuff like this to Elon Musk uh here's a
tweet from her is this the freedom of
speech you want Elon Musk how about
copyright infringement is that fine by
you too and then it has this picture uh
forgive me if you're if you're listening
on audio if you have children then you
probably shouldn't be she has a picture
of her dress like a lady in Little House
in the prairie and I guess someone
Photoshopped it saying my vagina smells
like cat piss I think
I think it's supposed to be What's that
show the handmaid's tale oh oh okay
which is just still hilarious but here's
the thing if there if you if there was
something as bad as she claims like
people are trying to destroy my
reputation copyright infringement these
threats you'd see something better than
an MS paint my vagina smells funny well
that's the best she had as far as
threats and an unsafe space yeah the
next tweet she's clarifying just to be
sure my vagina does not it does not like
cat piss I'm like I think you're
protesting a little too much it's more
like pencil shavings
so much drier tuna I don't know
so
it's something a cat might eat out of a
can yes
sorry please deliver now
she also went on to say on The View that
broadcast cackling hot flash that uh
Elon Musk this is what's so wonderful
right they always absolve themselves of
what they can do so for example Alyssa
Milano is a
multi-multi-multi-multi-millionaire yeah
I don't know what the royalties pay they
should pay less but they do pay for her
shows uh you have a lot of these actors
you have the Leonardo DiCaprio's when
they go out and they talk about uh they
talk about climate change yeah they go
well no no those people are really
wealthy hold on a second to everyone
else like if you go to Uganda if you go
to Zambia they think you're super
wealthy like why aren't you giving tens
of millions out of your tens of millions
oh no no that only counts when it's a
billion it only counts when it gets to
the billions number kind of like a
former Vice President Joe Biden says we
need to tax the ultra wealthy when is it
ultra wealthy well not as much as I make
which is around 400 000 so we're going
to increase the top rate for people who
make more than 400 000 don't ask
questions
so you and no one else talks about it
Elon Musk according to Alyssa Milano and
this is the virtue signaling these are
people who will never actually
contribute to society Elon Musk could
save world hunger if he gave all of his
money to UNICEF I'm kind of like like
I'm so annoyed with all of these these
billionaires with like the exception of
a few but especially Elon Musk like some
are okay you buy Twitter to destroy it
yeah for 40 billion dollars right 40
billion dollars Elon Musk imagine if he
donated that money to UNICEF I know yeah
he would change the world there would be
there would be no hungry kind of like if
you just shut up right
I love this narrative by the way this
was yesterday I love the narrative that
he's destroying Twitter their user
numbers are at record highs yeah
profitability is that record I'm like
that's destroying a business because you
don't like that he fired a bunch of dead
weight hey by the way Twitter still
works and they have like 7 000 viewers
what happened it's a private company
they can do whatever they want and in
this case you can't you can go to
communist by Tick Tock you can go to
Facebook
it is Snapchat what's up the point is
this is the only one that doesn't ban
people for points of view we for the
longest time we're just saying a we just
need an even playing field how about at
least even playing field for one they
are freaking out saying can you believe
it there's now even one
well they go to fake compassion it's
like what about the other 95 of the
people that own Tech you think they're
not billionaires where are they donating
their money to exactly you're just upset
it's not an echo chamber that it was you
know prior yeah no they're absolutely I
couldn't have said it better myself and
by the way Elon just to be clear there's
a track record here yeah he told the U.N
world food program he said if the wfp
can describe in this thread exactly how
six billion dollars will solve world
hunger I will sell Tesla stock right now
and do it exactly so he got called out
in kind of the same way about the person
who's in charge of that U.N world food
program yeah so he said they could just
if they would just get together and six
billion dollars could Solve IT Elon did
that and said and it has to be fully
transparent on where this money I wonder
why he would say that is because they
waste all of the money typically it's
just somebody in Africa who's gotten
very very rich oppressing people yes
saying yes are my people are hungry
please give me more money the guy bacter
is like no no no I said we could we
could help yeah I said we could help oh
no oh I see the miscommunication you
thought that I said
no no I said we could help Which is far
more nebulous and doesn't hold me
accountable yeah it was hilarious
he got called out by the way you can
comment below I have some examples
comment if you think you know where I'm
going if you're watching this in real
time so uh the American government by
the way already gives 1.4 billion
dollars a year yeah it's combined
American government and private sector
combined American government Americans
sorry I should say the American
government is somewhere around 850
million I think oh you have it up there
884 million oh yeah 475 million from the
private sector uh just to be clear 2022
26 billion dollars in Aid uh was
delivered by the United States of the
Middle East North Africa sub-Saharan
Africa 13.8 billion dollars alone to
sub-Saharan Africa
right and we have how many billions of
dollars have been given to the Ukraine
now at this point well tens of millions
of dollars yeah we're losing count but
they're still hungry yeah not to mention
do you have any idea how we've spent
trillions in the war on poverty here in
the United States this is the beauty of
the left is well no no no I Alyssa
Milano I don't need to do it Elon Musk
should do it I can't do it but if
someone else gives enough money what
about what you can do and then they give
crap to people like Jordan Peterson or
even people here we say hey make your
own bet what can you do are you tithing
is 10 of your multi-million dollar
income being given to charity what is it
that you can do but this is the thing
the left sees the central government or
other people's money as the church this
is why I've always used the analogy
here's what the left is
the left is Ebenezer Scrooge
pre-redemption the right is Ebenezer
Scrooge after he's had his come to Jesus
moment the left is are there no prisons
are there no poor houses my money goes
there and I spend enough and they're
better to use them and then afterwards
he says hey you know what let me support
this private charity and a great deal of
back payments are due and I won't give
you a penny less I assure you he goes
from saying God
do it not not my job too
comment upon me to do something stop
someone else to do it because they're
doing it to the tune of trillions of
dollars and it's also predicated on a
lie that more money equals
better results yes well we've been
that's worked like a charm for our
Public Schools hasn't it he also bought
a company there's a difference it
doesn't mean that he doesn't have other
money and other money to go to Charities
it's just a stupid argument to try to
make somebody look bad and if Elon had
donated money to them I think it
wouldn't be exactly surprising that they
all went against him for that and then
against that charity right yeah there's
no there's no way to win this no none
they're just basically throwing a
Band-Aid on the problem too they're not
solving world hunger meaning a
self-sustaining program is being built
so that hunger will no longer exist in
these countries just look at the United
States of America all the money that you
just talked about we're giving to
overseas corporations we've thrown
trillions of dollars at it here in the
United States over the past couple of
decades I have no idea how many years
that would Encompass but 10 20 30 years
since the war on poverty has began hey
Mission Control you guys can give us
that number and how much we spend
annually the government on like food
stamps and EBT but we're still getting
worse yeah but according to commercials
and you'll see a lot of them this time
of year because they want people to give
it's a good time of year to kind of be
reminded that there are people less
fortunate almost 15 percent of children
are food insecure in the United States
that's 584 000 children in the United
States literally hungry yeah and we have
all the resources in the world
apparently and we still haven't figured
it out it's because you throw a Band-Aid
and by the way that's it this is the
same government sure they provide EBT
cards sure absolutely of course they
provide food stamps this is the same
government that dumps milk
to fix prices yeah and then provides
Farm subsidies Michigan Right remember
cherries remember that one year ago you
told me that yeah and uh we had no
Cherry crop cherries are very
Persnickety crop which is also another
example as to why the climate change
issue is not what they claim it to be
cherries require a very slow long
thawing winter If it freezes at all
again if you have any extremes the
cherries die well what happened is we
had a shortage of cherries one year
because we had a kind of you know we had
I don't know Indian summer is there an
Indian winter equivalent I don't know
Native American cold snap whatever it is
you want to call it that's better but
the issue is uh you'd think okay we have
a surplus because we had record Sherry
yields nope they make them dump them you
can see it if you go to Michigan they
make the farmers dump their cherries
otherwise the price would go too low so
let's spend a bunch of money to feed the
poor hey how about you just feed the
Homeless the cherries and the milk make
sure you have enough bathrooms working
that's not lost on me but the point is
you're you're literally wasting food as
a matter of policy so take that and
times it by a thousand different
policies that's what your billions of
dollars are going into and that's why
all of a sudden 20 30 40 billion dollars
trillions of dollars in the war on
poverty don't go where it's supposed to
go because the government can't stop
stepping on its own Johnson yeah well
and uh sorry in 2020 the supplemental
nutrition assistance program it costs
79.22 billion dollars 79 billion dollars
in the United States that was up uh one
year yeah yeah and it was up um almost
20 billion from 60.4 billion the
previous year geez so 70 some 79 billion
dollars being spent in the country that
has the best infrastructure the most
opportunity to end Hunger of any country
in the world this is just like communism
well if we do it right show me a country
in the world that has a better
opportunity to end Hunger in their own
country spending billions and billions
on it that has done it right you guys
don't know how to do this all you know
how to do is throw money at causes and
feel good about yourself for doing it
this is how you feel good before they
should all be eating you know
yeah I mean really it should be but at
least at least a chuck roast yeah I
would say but I mean really that's a lot
of cash yeah I would say a really nice
sirloin with a little bit of gold
shavings and lobster on yes I believe so
how about this I know this is
controversial and I'm not talking about
people who are truly disabled and unable
to do this but how about we just go back
to like an old principle if if you do
not work you do not eat oh that's your
kind I thought you was going to go to
the white replacement Theory I'm just
saying good Bible Bible had a solution
for the Hunger problem they also had a
glacier you couldn't Harvest all of your
crops and the poor could come in yeah
and work for it and get food so that
they could survive this is we I think
we've had the solution poverty doesn't
uh strike you like a bandit something
like that no you're absolutely right and
you just mentioned you just touched on
something hey Christmas people are more
charitable people are more likely to
give
why is that
is it because of secularism is it
because of Santa Claus it's because of
modern Christendom Mercy charity these
are not Universal values go and try and
find a disciple of Coney who values
charity and Mercy by the way hit the
like button if you're paying attention
YouTube wants you to believe that we are
all dead the algorithm you cannot find
this show if you type it in verbatim and
of course you can smash the rumble
button they're not uh not to be outdone
sorry I should say uh someone else is
leaving Twitter oh really and this one's
a little sad because it's someone who we
were off we were all fans of this
gentleman at one point uh Jim Carrey
announced that he's leaving Twitter but
here's the thing Jim Carrey didn't just
go on The View or whatever male
equivalent there's a show with Danny
bonaducci at one point I don't know the
other half I think it was called it was
terrible because they let each other
talk for that
[Applause]
Jim Carrey left his audience with this
weird
he could just say I'm leaving and
instead he decided to say it through
this
when I say it I mean
um
yeah I mean clinically insane cartoon
that he helped animate sweet
[Music]
[Music]
s
ha ha
that certainly gets the point across
yeah yeah
wow I I missed Fire Marshall Bill all
right I watched that but oh oh he's
leaving Twitter
alrighty then oh that's what that meant
yeah
what'd you think boy those herpes have
rotted us yeah they really have really
he needs a syphilis wig oh my goodness
some powder
um here's something else that you're
also starting to see and this is why the
left in the media they want a
Stranglehold on Pig Tech someone like
Jim Carrey obviously very funny in some
very funny films yeah what happens is
when you take away all the producers you
take away all the writers you take away
all the directors in the makeup and the
production they can't make it work
he's not creative enough to make it work
funny guy funny actor funny comedic
actor had some funny impressions that he
did absolutely
but when it's yeah you know what you eat
what you kill be an independent content
creator they can't compete this is the
kind of crap that Jim Carrey thinks is
groundbreaking now it's really sad
because I think we're all fans of Jim
Carrey at one point when he was in his
prime one of the funniest men on Earth
but Mr Carey now that you're leaving
Twitter uh it's time to close
I don't believe that you exist but there
is a wonderful fragrance in the air you
don't believe certain icons have the
power to make change to think
differently to be bold to inspire others
Artistry you're one of them on the Good
Foot
time to close
endings and Beginnings are ending and
beginning now
I guess you call it the left side I I
just call it the sensible side
everything that Trump touches does
exactly absolutely yeah he's radioactive
let's just face it what is your name
Molly Molly I'm sorry I should ask you
Molly that's not really who you are
anyway
Molly yeah yeah we'll find out different
thank you very much Molly Molly for now
[Music]
times
[Music]
he fancies himself a compassionate
liberal
if you watch his catalog of personal
interactions he's an arrogant prick he's
an American prick and he thinks he's a
guru thing uh you won't feel like that
I'm so glad that we got that from
Comedians in Cars with coffee and I'm so
surprised that Jerry Seinfeld didn't
just say what are you doing look at
Jerry's body language though like when
he goes you'll feel you you'll find out
different you just see him like to find
out different what do you know who she
is wait wait why are you being crazy it
doesn't make any sense get this guy a
resume does he take hallucinogenics
every day yeah yeah all day no don't you
know big Pharma just wants to trick you
and keep you a zombie you got to take
more shrooms yeah yeah no no he's
completely sane that's why he has a
Lighthouse Keeper that's naked calling
on angels to light the world is that
what it was I thought it was a trans
pregnant man no well you know I can see
why you were confused it's uh it's a
little close right away it was riveting
yes and by riveting we mean gross and
the song oh just listen to it for days
tracked laser beam tracking okay this
brings us to speaking of trans pregnant
people uh yay former Vice President
Biden's Department of energy employee
there's a long title so let me just tell
you this is they were in charge of uh
disposing of nuclear waste or taking
care of the nation's nuclear waste this
person and also have you ever seen
somebody who looks like they work in
nuclear waste more right well also yeah
so this is Sam Britton uh nuclear keep
that up there that's nuclear waste
disposal specialist and also a
professional Matt Damon method project
so
this could happen was charged with a
felony after stealing a two thousand
dollar Vera Bradley suitcase from the
Minneapolis-St Paul Airport but by the
way after not having checked a bag right
on the flight it wasn't just taking your
back and someone else's bag not a
mistaken oops grabbed the wrong bag it's
I didn't even check a bag but I like
that bag I guarantee you this is a part
of his her Z's regular travel plans so
if you want to carry-on or or check
don't worry about it no no I'll just
I'll get my clothes into the airport
I'll get one of those free bags on the
carousel yeah nice bag you've got why
would I pack don't you know that they
just come out yes
take a bag leave a bag I mean some
people no financial responsibility is
unreal just a waste like dumping the
bills
[Music]
just just shake some this bag sounds
like Maracas nailed it fun bag
so tell me if you know about it but
Britain uh was actually seen on
surveillance camera taking the bag again
after not even taking a bag uh now this
person they I'm going to use the
grammatically incorrect term because
we're on YouTube and they hate Society
they initially denied taking the bag
okay this comes from Business Insider
saying uh if I had taken the wrong bag I
am happy to return it but I don't have
any clothes for another individual that
was my clothes when I opened the bag
okay bad grammar yes well it's they now
this person so this this is it's not
just a lie this is an elaborate lie it
really is this was I don't know these
are my own clothes yes come on there's
no way to prove this there's not
computers or ways to know if I check
something yes no no no by the way this
was a month later yes that Britain was
tracked down and said no no no those
were my clothes in the bag two hours
later I'll let you say in just a second
but took the clothes out of the bag the
story confirms dumped them in a hotel
room and just kept the bag yeah a month
later was seen on two separate flights
in airports on security cameras with
said bags like yes this is mine also
when they took the bag I said it
correctly that time yes took the name
tag off of the bag so well one does
identification so it's complete accident
yes total accident yes this looks like
my Phantom bag I didn't check by the way
you know the only reason that they
dumped the contents and kept the bag is
because there were clothes for men yes
ew gross
that's the real crime here yeah it's
like you can't even just pick a random
bag from the free bag Carousel and find
yourself some edible panties these days
what's the world coming to TI edible
just cotton yes exactly oh it's more of
a stuffing really yeah oh my God an
edible she looks like she feeds on
wasters yes
they looks like they bring them up a
great day up again bring they Britain up
again these bring them up again these
looking crazy the picture yeah they look
like they crawled out of a sewer that's
why it was like when I heard bag when I
saw the top of the article I thought it
was like stole a bag of waste to eat
Botox no just call it back and by the
way you know this isn't the first time
this person stole the bag this is the
thing this person lied elaborately this
person was caught and here's what I will
say the macro to this is we turn a blind
eye to all of the character issues if
someone claims trans how do I know I've
done it you're talking to a
peer-reviewed published Professor just
because I put on a wig in fake boobs
good for you you guys can go back see
Matheson watch the academic conference
it's absolutely ridiculous no one
questions you it's oh you hit and run
you're a woman of the year yeah
yeah just do what you want live all the
time oh wait you you mean you stare at
uh the girls in your locker room with
the Raging erection NCAA record yeah
yeah sure why not ah captain of the swim
team yes captris I don't know the words
aye aye they
so Britain called the police to later
change the story admit to the theft
thinking that this again the former Vice
President Biden's nuclear waste
specialist uh thinking they would of
course hey I came clean about it uh not
understanding that there are
consequences now appears to be on the
run somewhere yeah um which uh actually
seems to be um what's is that oh yeah
that's right now what's happening on CNN
coming the story right now
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
well it's considered a more serious
felony if it's a Samsonite that's true
yes it is true just don't take somebody
else's bag and you won't get your arm
broken hey you know what you can take
take yourself to the firing range and go
try a Walther uh they're a sponsor to
the show our longest standing sponsor
they have the balls to sponsor the show
this is a Walther PDP I highly recommend
it they have the performance trigger the
slide serrations uh just go to
waltherarms.com you can find a dealer
look I don't really need to do a whole
pitch there are a lot of firearms out
there that are great I'm not crapping in
any other firearm company at a certain
point it's like you have Mercedes you
have BMW BMW BMW yeah BMW uh just go try
the Walther they support this show
Google review Walther PDP review go try
it you'll probably buy it all right we
can move on now to what was that that
looked like it was so that looked like
it was Buffalo Bills that's completely
out of focus what are you trying to do
this yeah but it's the red chair behind
it that makes it look like I mean I'm
not great I didn't know what that was
either with the red background yeah big
blurry firearm oh yeah I like the hand
the Firearms aren't blurry in real life
folks no they're not no no there you can
see them perfect they're not 3D printed
so Balenciaga okay we have to talk about
this because this is something that
everyone has been talking about and I
think we agree in spirit but I also
think that truth matters so here's my
question for you as we move on to the
segment comment below what is satanism
what is satanism uh I think by the way
uh we need that thing to come in it's
like this comment comes up there's a
delay to the ding like it's a fuse okay
all right so what is satanism
distracting me I can continue talking
man it was like I was talking
about it's like the cancel toast button
it's like a ding should come first yes
there you go yeah that makes sense it's
like toast now you've got good we're
gonna give Yakuza a triangle so
if you don't know about this story if
you haven't been following the news okay
let me set this up for you and then
unfortunately there's been some
misinformation on both sides and I I
don't want that to detract from the fact
that yes you do have a secular humanist
industry in the entertainment industry
in Hollywood and they are coming for
your kids just to be clear so
unfortunately when you come out and you
say something that is dishonest
deliberately you give the left and in
that you don't need to give them so let
me set up the story uh the fashion I
guess the term is always fashion house I
don't know what that means Balenciaga
obviously they've been in hot water for
some terrible decisions and I think this
is is this the clip with the bondage
bears
um yeah okay I don't know yeah I believe
it
[Music]
ignorant uh
[Music]
you know wait hold on a second pause
this real quick okay this is what this
is a guy criticizing this shoes I think
that's their opinion of their own shoes
oh this is the guy who works there are
terrible I think so all right that's the
wrong clip here's the right one clip
Balenciaga is known for its edgy designs
the brand often pushing the envelope but
critics are accusing the brand now look
at that fashion house faux campaign it's
not a faux pas yeah here it comes this
morning fashion house are they going to
show the images like Kim Kardashian and
celebrated in songs by lizzo
and cardi B
facing backlash accused of sexualizing
children in a controversial that
allegedly if we see it the luxury brand
now for these photos showing little
girls in Balenciaga sweats it's just
like your Penguins bears and what
appeared to be BDSM inspired harnesses
on the desk showing an extra school from
the 2008 U.S Supreme Court opinion USV
Williams which upheld the
criminalization of pandering of child
pornography yeah what appear what appear
to be double-sided dildos well on a
second it's a silicone phallus with two
glands penises on it allegedly no I'm
looking right at it that's what it is in
fact a double-sided dildo it could be
something else what could it be meat
tenderizer that's just a My Little Pony
with a special horn yes exactly no Pony
no pony
a horn
okay it's a double-sided all right all
right we'll give you that one fine hair
so finger trap of sorts
let's go through uh one of those things
that uh you know keeps falling out of
your hands if you have to grab the
dollar store it's like soap yeah like
one of those uh Magic hankies is right
you know there's stuff the point is
there's no sexualization of children
aside from um well everything you see
behind it's Pierce that's disgusting yes
that's gross so let's uh break this down
really quickly so on November 16th
Balenciaga released these pictures from
their gift shop campaign the cruising
Bear yes yes exactly one of them comes
complete with a paneled van
so it's uh these are uh teddy bears BDSM
yeah I guess alcohol props to lining the
bed can we bring that picture up again
there's some things that you might have
missed it's like one of those little
exercises in the back it looks like Mr
slave went to build a bear yes exactly
well put yes yeah the Folsom Street Bear
yes
and this was nice community and it was
shot by an Italian photographer named
Gabrielle gallimperio surprised that an
Italian might be living in a
hypersexualized society
thank you for trying out loud so
Balenciaga did Apologize yeah
which I would argue is not enough
because you've sexualized children but
they did apologize saying we sincerely
apologize for any offense our holiday
campaign may have caused I love by the
way I would try to not cause offense
they're like but we still look sure we
may have had children with ball gags and
leather chains and whips but we didn't
say Christmas we did say holiday so we
think that counts for some for us we're
on the same team still yeah these are
for all children yes could be could be
Kwanzaa sex closets yes we're not we're
not here to discriminate it's a Hanukkah
Israeli sex hammock I mean really your
imagination is the limit
so we sincerely apologize for any
offense our holiday campaign may have
caused our plush bear bags should not
have been featured with children in this
campaign hold on hold on I don't have a
problem with bare bags being featured
it's BDSM Bear right it's being featured
that's a good point don't have a problem
with bear bags nope don't have a problem
I mean we're the bags with bears in them
you do not want to get that close to a
bear bag believe me the last thing that
you feel before the sweet Embrace of
death is it gliding across your face
just watch Grizzly Man go I'm talking
about these bear bags don't have a
problem with bags shaped like Bears
don't have a problem with children no I
don't even have a problem with BDSM
stuff in your own you know your own gay
clubs I love it it's when you combine
the three that parents start saying I
think this is a little bit of a of a of
a degenerate Bridge Too Far
well yes BDSM is bad BDSM bear is like
well okay but BDS and Bear Child
campaign is the words you don't want to
see match together yeah I think that's
fair to say I think it's fair but that's
me Mr old-fashioned I don't under it it
just feels like they're really trying to
creep in all this stuff like this is
very deliberate yep and it's very
disgusting and it needs to be called out
this this entire sexuality of kids is
just getting to be it's way too far well
here's the thing the people who say well
I think children should be able to
transition you have no leg to stand on
because that inherently is sexualizing
children because you're changing their
sexual capabilities and proclivities for
the rest of their life you can so in
other words conservatives people out
there who say yeah we shouldn't
transition children we shouldn't be
sexualizing children people who
supported Florida saying you're not
teaching sexual issues to kids kids uh
kids grade K through 12. great this is
consistent if you're a liberal you
cannot oppose this and support those
things you can't it's not possible so
truth matters here and consistent so
they said we have immediately removed
the campaign from all platforms a parent
of one of the child models by the way
and I use this term loosely is defending
the shoot saying that the pictures were
taken out of context and the experience
was enjoyable this is a parent by the
way saying no parent would actively
encourage the child to take part in
something which was pornographic you did
and I think the publicity surrounding
what happened has been blown out of all
proportion it's not keep in mind people
say well isn't the parent know best no
the parent doesn't know best just like
this is the same argument that's used
wouldn't a mom know best for her child
if she wants to give her puberty
bloggers no you do not if parents always
knew best there wouldn't be crack babies
parents always knew best she wouldn't
have gone for this check to sexualize
her daughter and now she's just
defending her poor decisions well of
course that never happens in the
entertainment industry parents don't
throw their children to the wall that's
never happened I just have one question
for this parent
did you look at the bear
do you care what did you think it was
you thought this was an enjoyable
experience to have a BDSM bear in your
child's hand in a picture that will live
forever by the way you thought that was
okay we're supposed to where this person
thought it was just a bare zip liner I
didn't know BDSM who can tell I thought
it was just leather that's a rock
climbing harness yeah why the hole for
the cross same thing when they walk into
the bar in The Sopranos the gay bar and
the dudes dancing with the other man
he's like it's a it's a goof like he
finally gets gone for [ __ ] day that's
the exact outfit the best way it's the
gay soprano Bear yes I mean Freddie
Mercury wouldn't have worn that no it's
too much for him Lady Gaga wouldn't wear
that under her meat suit no it's she was
not created that way now if you think
that children shouldn't be full stop
sexualized in any way again hit the like
button like share comment below it
always helps the algorithm on YouTube
um here's something else by the way uh
this is uh what is this is this the same
brand they released pictures and it's
campaign
how do you say are they doing do
Americans say garter robe guard robe by
the way means your wardrobe in French so
sorry I'm not trying to be an arrogant
prick I don't know the right wrong way
to say it I'm not trying to be one of
those people who says I like eating
fajitas that's not it I just don't know
the right way to say this in English
okay you know what though admonish me
for being a dick saying it the French
way I should say it the Americanized way
I just don't know how I don't know how
to do it I respect you taking
accountability it's just impossible for
me because in my head it's I mean I
learned to read and write French before
English anyway what's the whole thing
you go I like some tacos
[Laughter]
I ordered a very basic ethnic foods in a
very ethnic way I do it no matter where
like if I just go and go I want some
[ __ ] bangers on mash
and nobody I want some [ __ ] you yeah
especially like some fish and chips if I
might yes
like that I didn't swear because I don't
like myself oh I don't know I'm about to
eat fish and chips so this is the new
campaign to have the pictures of the
Garda robe campaign all right and uh
this campaign of course features Nicole
Kidman Bella Hadid
uh this I guess the shoot included the
United States versus Williams document
yeah that's the document that they were
referring to that showed in 2008 that
the Supreme Court upheld that you can't
have from child pornography on that side
I didn't know that's included in the new
photo shoot that was included in that
photo shoot so when they referenced it
in the news piece they were referencing
that issue did Nicole Kidman have any
questions of that photo shoot like huh
what are the papers what what are those
papers over there by the table are those
are just there's something about how I
can't be a pedophile you're not showing
a portray me like a pedophile yeah a
pedophile you're gonna try me like a
pedophile no no it's saying that we're
not what would you have to say that
you're not what's happened before I came
in this room here I think she was just
too busy dazzling everybody with her
range as an actress yes why does she
sound like a man too and her translucent
pigment like she's a deep sea creature
yes does she just stay in the dark and
they get her at times I can't be in the
sun too long yes
I'll I'll cancer what was that movie
with the person in the basement just
recently uh uh the woman in the basement
with the ramen hair oh that was
Barbarian
Nicole Kidman yep so yeah you're right
the shoot included the United States
versus Williams decision document and
that decision of course ruled that uh
you can't Pander to Children sexually
you can't use them to Pander you can't
basically exploit uh children in a
sexual way
um and also was featured a book with the
art of Michael borman's right there in
the background so that's circled it's
just and by the way that that author by
the way regularly features graphic
depictions of yes of children pretty
pretty rough stuff so it's kind of weird
it's like we've got the anti-pedophile
legal documents but then we've got the
pedophile author so
it's a duality of sexualizing kids and
then we have the actual photos
sexualizing kids yes yes it's the third
but they're just the negatives yes it's
no big deal she's they're kept here for
safekeeping ridiculous
so let's be clear there are a lot of
celebrities right it'd be one thing if
it's just some Rogue uh fashion house
but you have Kim Kardashian obviously
have Nicole Kidman you have Bella Hadid
and Kim Kardashian did come out against
the brand her credit saying as a mother
of four I have been shaken by the
disturbing images uh the safety of
children must be held with the highest
regard and any attempts to normalize
child abuse of any kind should have no
place in our society period as for my
future with Balenciaga I am currently
reevaluating my how about this yeah
exactly how about instead of okay so I
don't think there should be any
sexualization of children as a mother of
four how do you follow that up with I'm
reevaluating
what because she's paid a lot yes that's
the issue I'm re-evaluating you should
re-evaluate your foot right up their ass
yeah it basically she goes on to say if
they're willing to accept responsibility
I'm like
yes oh yeah we are bad I'm sorry we're
still pedophiles are you still cool
working with us yeah like that's that's
no you
eat right done yeah somewhere else yeah
you have enough money to step away and
on top of it you have enough money to
say that it did damage to you because of
the photo and you represent that
property right and now she's getting 200
000 a month in child support from what I
understand divorce settlement really
that's a hefty 2.4 mil those sex tapes
really do they're worth their weight in
gold my gracious we're in Balenciaga yes
and Balenciaga where is Ray J
that's a good point I don't know it's
all his fault so this is uh and this is
the issue people can be powerful and
still be coward
I was about to say Kanye West sorry uh
Kim Kardashian Kim Kardashian is a
coward Nicole Kidman is a coward Bell
Hadid is a coward if you're not willing
to stand up against basically child
pornography at the very least child
sexploitation if that is not a line in
the sand for you then there is no line
there is nothing that would push you
over the edge into actually living out
any sort of principles this just like
progressivism for progressivism's sake
is corrosive it's evil it's the same
thing when pursuing power for Powers
these people often we say what are they
doing they don't need the money they
don't need any more Fame they don't need
Balenciaga it's a compulsion and it's
compulsion by the way that doesn't eat
think about that Kim Kardashian is going
to reevaluate a relationship basically
my what she's saying is my dignity my
protection my mothering protective
Instinct of my children is for sale for
the right price that's what you're
saying
uh thankfully a lot of her fans have
kind of hit back out or saying this is
not enough like there is no reevaluation
when something like this happens but
what do you expect when someone is quite
literally famous for acid plants of
course sorry all natural like the rock
where's the shot for that
there's no way even though I I don't
mind it yeah well until you see like a
full when you see like a full body shot
of Kim Kardashian it's like when you see
Kermit's legs it just looks weird yeah
no it's like it's alien-ish but she's
still she's very she's a pretty lady and
I think she gets a lot of crap
well well yeah I mean look yeah is that
what's in there it's a factory
conveyor belt
kill wins
Pete Davidson's been there yeah well
Pete Davidson's been everywhere so also
yay not yi yi not Kanye yay
who's worked with Balenciaga in the past
uh issued his own statement
you know they they tried to destroy me
and press they tried to destroy all of
my businesses at the same time and the
world saw it and no one's saying
anything
you know as far as like none of the
celebrities so this just shows you all
celebrities are control you don't see no
celebrities talking about the Balenciaga
situation right so that just shows you
all of these celebrities out here don't
let them influence you in any way
because they're controlled by the people
who really influence the world
there's no such thing as a celebrity
influence now here's the thing what he
just said most of that is right yes
Kanye West can be right about some
things and be wrong about it or be right
in his statement and maybe wrong on some
of the premises of a statement so let's
be really clear here this is also I
think an important point he's saying no
one is talking about it here's the
problem that's the gaslighting you are
talking about it a lot of people are
talking about it and then the left the
media tries to tell you that this is
just part of a far right smear so first
enough of you are talking about it that
November 29th Balenciaga completely
cleared the Instagram wiped it removed
all of these uh pictures the whole
campaign
only they they had a they put up a
picture up there with the apology
roommate that's the only thing that
remains the apology
picture of an apology okay so in other
words
there must have been enough backlash for
them to have to react this way which
makes it so bizarre and sometimes
sometimes you get a moment like this
just a moment of like manna from the sky
where they didn't they didn't coordinate
on their playbook because the New York
Times still trying to paint the Scandal
as a far right smear here's a quote
references available a lot of cutter.com
as online criticism of the campaign
spreads the story was picked up across
right-leaning media Outlets including
the New York Post and the prime time Fox
News show Tucker Carlson the show has
helped to publicize mainstream Q Anon
the internet conspiracy that quote a
group of Satan worshiping Elites who run
a sex child sex ring are trying to
control our politics and media and
here's the problem don't give them a win
that they haven't earned they're looking
to compare you to Q Anon they're looking
to fact check you on something that's
inconsequential the facts here are
enough if you just stick with the facts
guess what people can see the New York
Times article and say well why don't
second are they mad about and they go
look at the pictures they say oh I'm a
parent I agree with them right are they
mad about the things that are actually
in the photographs not just the Bears
which we've touched on as well but the
the Supreme Court decision the book like
come on you don't have to be a rocket
scientist to look at this and go
something else is going on here this
wasn't an accident this was done by
Design and somebody signed off at
Balenciaga and said yeah that looks like
an ad that we want to not somebody an
entire room of people yeah an entire
hierarchy of people signed off and it's
not that they signed off saying oh I
don't even think they thought this is
going to be controversial you know this
is going to be clickbait I think they
didn't think of it because they live in
a world that chews up and spits out its
young and we're going to get into that
this is not a unique example in
Hollywood when they say me too they say
rape culture they're not entirely wrong
when these celebrities say it it exists
only in their area of the world only in
their industry and of course places like
Saudi Arabia and of course places you
know in sub-Saharan Africa but it
doesn't exist anywhere outside of Los
Angeles and maybe New York but certainly
in the entertainment industry there is a
rape culture certainly in the
entertainment industry in Hollywood
there is a child pornography culture but
here's the thing before we get to that
there are some people on the right who
unfortunately have been misrepresenting
the situation all the references are
being made available to you because I
think that truth matters I don't want to
see us make a misstep when we're dealing
with something this consequential this
is a tweet from uh I think curios light
has more than 66 000 likes it's been
shared by a bunch of people on the right
uh bring this up here it's overlay d8
says the Devil in Disguise a lot of
volkova she's been one of the main
stylists in Balenciaga since 2014. she
has a relationship with an accused
pedophile we can't only boycott
Balenciaga but also the people behind it
there are a couple of problems here
that's not that's not a lot of okova
okay it's a model from a Chinese fashion
show well Coba hasn't worked at
Balenciaga since 2018.
just to be clear now the truth is vocaba
has shared satanic imagery on her
Instagram
no current association with Balenciaga
and that's not the person in the picture
don't share Lies when the truth is
enough please please and don't go oh
[ __ ] it doesn't matter let's no if
you'll hear I'm not saying don't lie
just because it's wrong it's ineffective
right exactly it gives them something to
point at and say see they're
exaggerating see that's not exactly
what's happening or it was this person
right exactly this is not the same thing
right you don't want to distract it's
almost like the comedy bit that you were
talking about just take a knee and take
the win right you're about to win an
argument what I think it was Bill Burr
Bank Bill burst yeah so it's just this
is one of those situations where you
don't have to use the Red Devil babies
picture you can just go and say they
posted this satanic imagery and have the
collage that's it you win done
Lil Nas X straddling Satan and selling
Nike sneakers with a vial of his blood
in it isn't enough you have to make [ __ ]
up
there's enough and by the way before I
ask you again it's wrong just processing
that sentence hey hey a child holding a
build a dong bear is enough
the only blood that should be on our
sneakers is that of a child's yes who's
making them and cuts their fingers
sewing and they're bleeding because we
force them to continue making the
sneakers nice just don't really believe
in anything we'll just call it a special
edition with red laces
so again my question to you is because
we're going to get to this in a second
what is Satanism and it always kind of I
you can comment below it always sort of
surprises me that um that Ding ah it's
driving me nuts it always sort of
surprises me when you have people out
there celebrities people on the right
who say ah this is a satanic cabal okay
what church are you involved with
why is it all of a sudden the people who
are not practicing Christians who want
to use the Satanism clickbait yeah Satan
is I believe the devil is real the devil
wants you to think that he's not real
just to be clear but we'll get to what
Satanism actually is before that here's
the thing Hollywood has a very long and
storied history with child exploitation
let's be clear here uh what do we have
we have a um oh this is a new one new
play pedophile play called downstate by
Bruce Norris
and by the way it's not just that
there's a play basically uh I guess I
should say uh
praising or portraying in a positive
light I don't want to misspeak and be
removed from YouTube from a pedophile
moderator it's not just that you have a
play that's Pro pedophile allegedly
it's that you have the media carrying
their water Washington Post there's a
columnist there Peter marks wrote a
review of the play take a guess glowing
Oh weird Norris proposes A variation on
this proposition at off-broadway's
playwrights Horizons I always love when
they have to say Off-Broadway because
that means they're a self-important
prick it also means it's not on Broadway
for good reasons yes exactly for a very
very good reason what I want you to do
is walk past the theater see where they
have Avenue Q playing and keep walking
until someone takes your wallet and then
you won't find that at the tkts stand so
he is uh this is the review uh he is
questioning what degree of compassion
should Society fairly hold out to those
who have served their time for sexual
abuse assault or rape downstate directed
with exceptional astuteness by Pam
McKinnon seizes on our reflexive
response to these crimes and shifts our
emotional Focus to the perpetrators let
me ask you this at what point do they at
what point does a person not warrant
your emotional Focus I I know I know if
they voted for Trump right you don't
care if they live or die right but when
someone rapes a kid or when someone
Grooms a kid and you understand the
recidivism rate at what point do you
actually focus on the victim rather than
the criminal I'm sorry this may seem a
little bit cold
I think there's nothing wrong with the
way we've been doing it since the
beginning of ever you rape a kid you
harm a kid in the tribe you're gone try
and come back you get an arrow through
the heart or you get a bullet to the
face
you leave Exile that's your we why for
the same reason that a dog that mauls a
child can no longer be let in a daycare
you are no longer allowed to be among
Society where you could do damage it's
just a risk that we can't take leave and
then if they through Force come back the
punishment has to be as severe as
humanly possible comment below if you
think if you think that's a little bit
too Stark of a contrast I'm giving them
the option to leave right that's that's
enough but so this play that wasn't just
so this this article is glowing this
play was fantastic they did a great job
with this in the play they're making the
point that we're treating pedophiles
people convicted of sexual crimes
against minors and other people too
harshly because we're not considering
the emotional distress that they're
going through in life and the isolation
and everything else whatever it is it's
not enough here's the one part of it too
that just makes it even worse one of the
plays characters is a victim of one of
the guys who's living in this basement
in a group of people that are living
together and they portray him as this
person who misguidedly comes back to
face his his you know Mentor essentially
somebody who abused him and to try to
get some closure he's like he's trying
to get some kind of closure in his wife
misguidedly says that this is probably a
good idea and he has no compassion for
this guy he paints him as the villain
he's the child who was abused who is now
an adult that is coming back to try to
get some closure as the villain in the
story and all the compassion goes to the
guy that raped him
that's what this play does this is far
more prevalent in our society than I
think people realize and the fact that
there's more people in Hollywood oh
absolutely but it no it goes on
everywhere there's a problem with sexual
abuse of children everywhere and the
reality is is the more people there are
the more this stuff is coming to light
because somebody who made this play
orders behind the door is producing it
has an agenda I firmly believe that
because it's too much of this crap going
on yeah it's a it's a conspiracy even
though you're watching it yes exactly no
I think you're absolutely here's the big
difference though is that at least
incest even if people in our society at
large being the United States uh aren't
as hard on pedophilia as we are aren't
as hard on child rapists they still have
to feign as though they're bothered by
it they don't write plays saying can't
we give them empathy only in the
entertainment industry do they openly
blatantly say hey we're not pro
pedophile but couldn't you put a Little
Love in Your Heart nope
well they're saying use the term minor
attracted person and that's when I was
like well you've officially lost me yeah
is that what we call them when we shoot
them yeah how about future room
temperature yeah like it's I don't
understand like it is it's a
it should it should be an execution yeah
I'm sorry if you rape a child yes it
should be you should be put to death
because you are a danger to children
you've had your chance to live you're
now an adult you're taking away somebody
else's you deserve to die that's how
I've always felt about it I agree with
you right because I don't want you out
and watch YouTube say that this is more
extreme than the people trying to groom
and by the way that is grooming just to
be clear creating a play like that that
you know a bunch of suburban white moms
who make up the entire Democratic voting
block and want to put their kids on
puberty blockers they'll be hey we're
gonna go into the city yeah we're
leaving Bronxville today let's go watch
the the pedophile supportive play can
you write a report afterwards what did
you think oh my child's so compassionate
no you are an abusive parent if your
role as a parent is not to protect your
child by any means necessary from sexual
predators you should give your children
up for adoption you should give them up
to another family if you are not willing
and I mean this I'm not just saying
someone who's a minor attracted person
who hasn't acted on it still deserves
severe severe Exile if someone is
actually committed child sexual
exploitation and it's happening to the
point that there's a huge industry that
exists there are more slaves on Earth
than ever right now in record history
over 40 million you know why a lot of
them are sex slaves yep which is just
another form of slavery almost a worse
form and most of slavery a lot of them
are children if you are not willing to
pull that trigger as a dad you're not a
dad
you're not a dad
and by the way people say cowards hey
you know what this is and I mean this
honestly if you have someone who is
raping your child someone who is someone
who is sexually abusing your child
here's the beauty of or if you're if
you're a woman who's being raped to be
clear people often say I hear like Sean
Penn say I think people will use guns or
cowards what you can't handle it with
your fists what if the guy's in a
wheelchair I don't know what if it's a
dad who has uh who has COPD and his
child's been raped a mechanical
advantage just as good and the
mechanical advantage should be used by
the state
I don't care if it's a lethal injection
I don't care if it's the chair or if
it's mid-act
thank God you have the ability to
protect you and yours and it doesn't
have to come down to who's taking the
liver King cycle let me give you a
couple of other examples here Corey
Feldman Corey Haim of course you're both
sexually exploited in Hollywood and they
were forced to work there for a very
long time they were passed around at sex
parties you have Brian Singer of course
was accused of raping Michael Egan as a
teenager of course you have Kevin Spacey
I mean countless people have come
forward
um here's another example
no I want to be clear not saying Michael
Bay did anything I just find it weird
yeah
that Michael Bay felt it necessary to
include this dialogue in Transformers I
just think it's weird
20. she's a 17 year old girl so we can
work this two ways one I punch you right
in the mouth and you call the police on
me or two
I just called the cops on you because
this is illegal she's a minor we're
protected mother Romeo and Juliet laws
we dated for a little while I was
sophomore and he was a senior it's fine
no it's not fine we've got a
pre-existing juvenile foundational
relationship statute
2705-3 what
Texas statute now a couple of things
here first off I also want to be clear I
don't think that people who are 19 years
old who are dating a 17 year old should
be put in prison with sex offenders just
to be clear however they could have made
that film and just had them both be 18.
well there's just no reason to put that
in there to encourage I'm not being
reflexive right I was like let's just
see why put that in there now I don't
even think Wahlberg was acting he's like
what
you're still trying to have sex with a
minor I don't know I don't care if
you're 19 she's 17. that's gross why
can't they just be why can't they just
leave 19. Michael but you're spending
too much time with special effects not
on human characters with real realistic
dialogue okay
I just love that we used to train we're
going to transform you if I'm a right
man it wouldn't have gone down like that
all right
all right this is the scene where we
teach you about Jack and Jill laws
involving sex with teens I'm sorry is
this Transformers am I on the right it
is yes this is the movie the kids will
watch if you want to make sure they're
very aware of this law and actions Jack
and Jill lost oh and this stick with the
tennis ball is Bumblebee go go yeah huh
how old are you Bumblebee
you have them talking about statutory
rape while you're jiggling that Bell
like you're some kind of dog animator to
Santa Claus at a shopping mall okay I
don't know what's happening
why does he have a card of the Jack and
Jill law hey he's done this before yeah
it's laminated he came prepared it means
the first one wore out he call him
Selleck because that's not his first
rule yeah but David was right next to
his condom in his wallet yeah it's like
look Jack and Jill we dated yeah
I took her out to dinner before I had
illegal sex yes in fact the law comes
and after the hill I did not put her
back together again oh no broke it off
now I don't know the Hodge twins are my
head okay so let's give you a few more
examples we'll just give you the some
sexual examples and of course you have
the same industry Drew Barrymore it's
the film crew encouraged her to down
glasses of champagne at 10 years old she
was on cocaine was in rehab at around
the age of 12 and then rather than
saying you people are all disgusting you
people are all exploitative she was at
the Academy Award saying I feel like you
people are like my family and I couldn't
been raised by a better family I don't
know if you know it's pretty rare for 12
year olds to be in rehab for Coke [ __ ]
yeah she thought the E.T puppet was real
yes and was still also doing Quaaludes
exactly which brings us to Roman
Polanski five women have accused of him
raping them as children all the way back
to 1977. 13 year old girl champagne and
Quaalude and they gave him an Oscar
after after over and wait he was in
France because if he came here he would
be arrested then you have another
example here that's creepy uh Dan
Schneider according to Zoe 101 actress I
guess uh Alexa Nicholas Schneider would
take pictures of kids feet I just threw
up in my mouth a little bit here's a
clip oh oh so yeah so that wasn't even
polarized like a digital camera and he
would go around with money and ask to
take photos of the kids feet
I'm sorry yes the kids feet yeah the
children's feet okay yeah their toes
okay and I remember thinking it was
weird and silly almost as a kid and I
remember my mom going don't go over
there my mom actually said no to it
mom's gone but I saw other parents
allowing their kids to do it I think
she's trying to say her mom actually
stopped her well that's good but that's
good she kind of forced if she just said
no yeah like don't do that no okay go
take pictures of your feet
but the Dan Schneider thing there's
actually tons of footage from different
shows yeah where it's like they're
putting food on their feet there's all
these foot fetish scenes like there's
like you know uh you have like them like
how do you eat a tin roof Sunday no
but like in bed like you know sucking
their toes and it's all Dan Schneider
produced television that guy is an
absolute creep he's an absolute creep
absolute creep and really it just comes
down to when they get caught again you
look back oh we have the signs but
sometimes they're caught and it's still
not enough no and Roman Polanski was
caught yeah he was giving her drugs that
don't even exist anymore
they did all the drugs all of them well
and Hollywood seems like the best place
to kind of preach morality that's why I
still love Ricky Gervais when it was
what was the Golden Globes that's
beautiful which one we did it no five
times he the one that was just like he's
into every single person including and I
like to call him this because president
Trump called him this Tim Apple yeah
right instead of Tim Cook
I know
files so
yeah yeah I've seen and they started
groaning goes why are you pooping it's
your friend it's not my friend
leaving
oh my gosh
um I would love to see him do the Jerry
list we wrote a whole script the Jerry
Lewis Telethon but it was Ricky Gervais
and he was just roasting kids remember
we just never really this is too mean
yeah so this brings us to I think this
is important right hopefully comment
below if you feel like this has been
clear for you as to what is true and
what is not true but this brings us to
this idea and you see these celebrities
out there saying this is obviously this
is practice Satanism and this cabal of
Satanist look
I want to be clear about something here
Satan is real matter of fact Alice
Cooper has a great uh description of it
he said you know I did a lot of things
even when I had straight when I was
distance from God but I never acted like
the devil didn't exist that's the danger
the real danger is acting like the devil
doesn't exist they don't want it to be
on full display they don't put it this
way it's very unlikely that the Satanism
is going to be actual on-screen Satanism
it's going to be the feat in some yams
it's going to be something subtle like a
play that then gets praised in the
Washington Post Satan the temptation of
evil is not going to show up as a
vampire it's going to show up as a sexy
secretary it's going to show up maybe as
a social worker who tries to plant some
ideas in your child's head that are
antithetical to the idea of the nuclear
family and Mom and Dad and just to be
clear to what we're talking about
satanism
I think the Church of the the the sort
of offshoot of Satanism that has the
most amount of members
it's also let me clarify this they don't
believe in God or Satan so um levae and
Satanism right Anton LaVey here's their
belief
is they don't believe in God
uh they don't believe that the Bible is
true but what they say is we hate
practice Christianity so much that if
you're going to believe this Fable if
you're going to believe this
allegorically we actually think that
Satan is the good guy and so they
professionally troll right they say to
us Satan is the symbol of that best
suits the nature of who we are carnal by
birth people who feel no battles raging
between our thoughts and feelings we do
not embrace the concept of a
soul-imprisoned body Satan represents
Pride Liberty individualism qualities
often defined as Evil by those who
worship external deities they don't
believe in loving your enemy they don't
believe no in Mercy they don't believe
in a certain set of sin they believe in
whatever feels best for you and if
someone gets in your way you can of
course do whatever needs to be done now
this is a perversion of what we know to
be good so I just want to be clear when
I say this yes yes I do think that this
industry not think Beyond any shadow of
a doubt is acting satanically because
they've idolized themselves they've
created a Graven image and it's
themselves they sacrifice and worship at
the altar of self of what feels good
right now what is most pleasurable to me
and here's the big difference if you're
a Satanist meaning a levian Satanist if
you're someone who rejects God I
understand that there are a lot of
things that for example as a Christian
God commands you to do that you don't
like keep in mind these are also the
same commands that say don't rape kids
right so you take the good with the bad
now some of them might not be
pleasurable
but we can't equate pleasure with
happiness pleasure with purpose pleasure
with fulfillment that's what Satanism is
and if you look at all of these issues
we come to this time and time again what
they're doing with Children what they're
doing uh whether it's drugs what they're
doing with
pick an agenda insert it here it's
almost always predicated on the idea of
pleasure masquerading as purposeful
happiness do not conflate the two
Satanism doesn't require a Rosemary's
Baby altar it just requires someone to
place their own selfish desires above
what they're called to be from God with
no regard for it so a hope of clarified
myself yeah and that's exactly what
Satan did right so you don't have to go
to a church that has Satan statues all
over the place and bow down in worship
and sing these weird songs and practice
rituals to be worshiping Satan Satan
basically said I will be like God I will
Ascend the Holy Mountain I will be above
God he was making himself God that's all
it is and so worship himself where do
people tend to worship themselves
everywhere right but Hollywood for sure
politicians for sure these places breed
people worshiping themselves
built on it Anton LaVey is doing it just
to get money from celebrities right I
mean that was really why it was created
was so you could mingle with the herd of
people that are self-indulgent right BFF
and it would be an easy sell it was
you're absolutely right you're saying
you just said something and it just and
be a 501c3 or just before no before that
what were you saying oh I don't know
Dave said something really funny and it
distracted well it happens I was just
saying that Satanism is worship of Self
in Hollywood and politicians those are
the two places that I see people
worshiping themselves more than anywhere
else maybe in Corporate America too yeah
you think you're this is the thing well
you know negotiate deals all the time
we're in business we talk to people all
the time if I go into a call if I go
into some kind of a meeting if I go into
one of these shows thinking that I'm all
that and that I've got all of this under
control then it's on me and my
performance is whatever it is and that's
me right right I go into those calls and
say God please help me to say the things
like when we pray before the show God
help us to have a clear thoughts and
have a clear heart in mind to put this
message out there let's let's not just
have it be us and it's always weird when
we hear back God has left this place
um we know but you know what's low scale
Satanism worship of self we see this
when we go that's incredibly perverse
how about the song that says you're
perfect just the way you are right
everyone thinks that sounds great it's
horrible no one is perfect just the way
they are you're awful we're all terrible
just to be clear human beings are not
inherently good we can become when
people say oh children are so innocent
and
I've have you watched kids at daycare oh
there is they steal and slap each other
yeah they don't care they require values
to be instilled it's not innate but the
idea that you're perfect you're
beautiful maybe you're not you don't
need to change a thing maybe you do you
know what else if he loves you he'll
take you exactly the way you are you
have nothing to improve nope how about
the fact that you leave your your your
contacts on the floor
hey just remember though that uh Jesus
is Victorious this just broke Chris
Licht of CNN he just released this
letter and he said today we will notify
a limited number of individuals largely
some of our paid contributors as part of
a recalibrated reporting strategy that
they'll be let go oh okay
around to say you suck your medial
medium I do want to and I don't uh this
is obviously something personal to you
but I think you've been pretty open
about being a recovering addict yes so
obviously the path of anyone who's
addicted to anything whether it's
alcohol whether it's drugs whether it's
sex it starts off of course as
pleasurable of course it does yeah well
yes to some degree it starts off as
pleasurable yes as socializing but it
does start off as pleasurable to a sense
yes but because it takes away pain but
does it mean happiness
no that's the exact opposite and why do
we and that's the point it's a problem
is Hollywood starts with that first half
and they don't tell you where it leads
and that's why we do it we do sometimes
say hold on someone you don't know the
end of the story now this is and I we've
talked about this an incredible amount
of respect not only for for what Dave
has done I know how hard it is having
had many family members who struggle
with addiction that's the ark but you
can't have that Arc unless you
acknowledge that pleasure isn't the same
as happiness you know something else
Yakuza here we know tool man you know
we've all we have a gym here at the
office wasn't something he really did
wasn't very pleasurable when you were
starting no but now you're starting to
see some results yes oh yeah and not
doing anything as you get older not
training that's not going to make you
happy when you can't play with your kids
we need to start earlier we can't just
have a bunch of reactionary [ __ ] and
I mean sometimes actual [ __ ] and
Photoshop saying Satanism because you're
not plugged into a church and you're not
reading the word and you're not actually
understanding that far earlier along the
trail we are dealing with the worship of
self because if you worship self what
happens if self is bad hey maybe on a
good day you end up with lizzo and fat
Pride worship self well you know what I
wouldn't say that's a good result or
maybe you worship self and you write a
pedophile play and maybe you worship
self and you're such a great playwright
reviewer critic sorry that you decide to
praise the play and that goes down the
trail and down the trail what Satanism
is this is the most effective tool but
Satan has in his in his tool chest is
selfishness
right pleasure being conflated with
happiness combined with subjective
morality
you take those two you can convince
anyone to do anything you want including
Build-A-Bear BDSM or puberty blockers
for six-year-olds how do you get that
far down the trail well hopefully I just
laid out a blueprint we're about to play
unrated or not which we absolutely could
not do on YouTube if any of this was
allowed on YouTube if you don't see us
on YouTube remember we're always there
on Rumble YouTube thank you we
appreciate it share the show everyone
watching piss off foreign